bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions économiques qui ne tirent pas
blanc
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de l'industrie de l'armement
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ces caches c'est
un terrain sur lequel la france n'a a
priori rien à envier à ses voisins
l'industrie de la défense l'hexagone se
place même sur le podium des plus gros
exportateurs au monde comment le pays at
il réussi à se hisser sur ce podium que
représente concrètement l'industrie à de
l'armement dans l'économie française
pour tenter de répondre à ces questions
nous recevrons en deuxième partie pierre
conesa essayiste et ancien haut
fonctionnaire
mais d'abord l'état des lieux de
l'industrie de la défense c'est avec le
tiroir cash d'antoine la sas
[Musique]
on en a parlé comme le contrat du siècle
et son annulation a carrément provoqué
une crise diplomatique
il faut dire que 56 milliards d'euros ce
n'est pas le genre de pertes qui passent
inaperçues et ça questionne sur l'impact
que ça peut avoir sur l'économie
française commençons par un petit état
des lieux en matière d'armes la france
est le troisième pays exportateur au
monde derrière la russie et les etats
unis elle représente 8,2 pour cent des
exportations mondiales selon le dernier
rapport de l'institut international de
recherche sur la paix de stockholm
en clair les armes sont un des fleurons
de l'industrie française
et pourtant tout n'est pas au top en
2020 comme n'importe quel secteur
d'activité les clients se sont faits
plus rares et la france a vu des prises
de commandes d'armes chuté à cause de la
pandémie passant de 8,3 milliards en
2019 à 4,9 milliards d'euros une chute
de 41% et pour les livraisons c'est
encore pire 2 9 points 9 milliards à 4,3
milliards d'euros elles ont chuté plus
que de moitié en matière d'emploi en
2019 la ministre de la défense florence
parly estimé que l'industrie de
l'armement représenté 13% des emplois
industriels du pays deux cent mille
personnes travailleraient de manière
directe ou indirecte dans ce secteur en
france et quatre mille petites et
moyennes entreprises seraient impliqués
on comprend donc pourquoi l'état
français misent gros sur son commerce
d'armes et pourquoi il est très présent
lors de la signature des contrats avec
les pays acheteurs sans parler du fait
qu'il est bien souvent actionnaires des
entreprises fabricantes navale group le
fabricant des fameux sous marin est par
exemple le détenu à 60 2 % par l'état
français normal donc que la pilule et eu
du mal à passer
[Musique]
olivia qu'est ce que cette crise des
sous-marins révèle selon vous sur l'état
de l'industrie de l'armement en france
est ce que ça signifie par exemple que
l'on est en train de perdre notre
compétitivité ou alors est-ce que c'est
lié plutôt à des questions géopolitiques
or ceux liés à des questions
géopolitiques et puis face et surtout
c'est surtout une grosse comédie de la
part de l'état parce que ce contrat en
fait était remis en cause quasiment
depuis le début
il ya eu une succession de retard il ya
une succession
d'augmentation de prix dues à ces
retards ce qu'on était parti d'un d'un
contrat qui était de 31 milliards
d'euros et on est arrivé à un contrat de
56 milliards d'euros donc s ils doublent
donc
et dès le début de l'année le contrat
était de plus en plus remis en cause par
le ministre de la défense australien et
c est donc qu ils ont fait semblant les
politiques français de s'apercevoir de
la chose juste au mois de septembre
non c'était il avait donné une date
limite pour régler un certain nombre de
problèmes et donc arrivant à cette date
limite le couperet est tombé et le le
contrat a été a été arrêté donc c'est
quelque chose qu'il a émise en scène
plus eu une réalité parce que je vous
dis ça faisait longtemps ce contrat a
été remis en cause sur les sur les sous
marins donc voilà après
ses pales c'est pas le seul contrat qui
a échoué parce que aujourd'hui vous avez
les belges donc la soi-disante europe de
la défense vous avez les belges qui si
mes souvenirs sont bons sons dans
l'union européenne qui ont choisi le
f-35 américains plutôt que le rafale
français donc il ya quand même un
certain nombre de contrats comme ça qui
nous échappent et pour des questions
alors après pas sûr que ce soit une
question de compétitivité mais il ya
d'autres questions d'ailleurs que notre
invité va pouvoir détailler beaucoup
mieux que moi et justement on va aller à
le rejoindre dans la deuxième partie
cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec pierre connaît sa pire connais ça
bonjour vous êtes essayiste ancien haut
fonctionnaire est votre dernier ouvrage
s'intitule le lobby saoudien en france
disponible aux éditions denoël merci
beaucoup d'être parmi nous et bienvenue
dans ces caches rien s'ils reconnaissent
à peut-être pour commencer une réaction
à ce qu'a expliqué olivier en première
partie et même question qu'est ce que
cette crise a des sous marins révèle de
l'état de notre industrie dans ce
secteur est ce que l'on a un problème de
compétence de compétitivité ou alors
est-ce que c'est lié à autre chose non
je suis moins je suis moins d'accord
avec olivier sur la question de la des
dysfonctionnements du système français
que sur le lac de géopolitique que les
américains ont voulu démontrer en
faisant annuler ce contrat pourquoi
parce que si vous voulez quand on a des
contrats de cette complexité c'est à
dire fabriquer des matériels de haute
technologie former des personnels faire
une partie des matériels ici puis
ensuite transféré du savoir faire
ensuite le faire là bas et c'est ce sont
des contrats extrêmement difficile par
exemple navale groupe avait des gros
problèmes pour trouver des pme
australienne qui soit capable d'avoir si
vous voulez la technicité indispensable
pour faire des sous marins parce qu'il
faut rappeler votre sous-marin ça
descend mais le problème c'est qu'il
faut que ça remonte et donc tout ce que
toutes ces difficultés là était un peu
ils rentrent à l'importance de ce
contrat donc sur le fond encore une fois
avec mon expérience je n'ai jamais vu un
contrat si vous voulez qu'ils soient
réalisés en temps et en heure il ya
toujours des discussions ne serait ce
que parce que le client des x change les
caractéristiques opérationnelles du
matériel ça donc c'est un ce sont des
contrats d'une extrême complexité qui
parfois occupe si vous la moitié d'une
pièce en volume de papier
deuxième remarque on a des gens et des
antécédents en 83 la france avait vendu
deux mirage 2000 à l'arabie saoudite et
la veille de la signature du contrat on
apprend que les saoudiens vont acheter
du tornado parce que les américains sont
toujours opposés à ce qui est du l'avion
de combat français en arabie saoudite
donc sur le fond moi j'ai tendance à
privilégier si vous voulez l'explication
géopolitique on est aujourd'hui dans une
situation où les américains font acte
d'autorité et on est bien en peine si
vous voulez de savoir comment on peut
répliquer
l'état est très souvent présent lors de
ces contrats
et il en quelque sorte le vrp du secteur
de l'armement et ce qu'il joue gros
ça toujours effet le rôle du président
de la république d'être un verre et sur
les gros contrats d'ailleurs pas que de
l'armement mais sur sur les contrats de
2,2
tout ce qui est centrales nucléaires etc
les mêmes les les trains express étant
c'est un vrai luxe et
souvenez vous qu'à chaque fois que
un président se déplace il se déplace en
général avec quelques grands capitaines
d'industrie
on le peu d'industries qui nous restent
mes plus grands capitaines de deux
grands groupes avec lui pour aller
vendre des contrats il facilité les
choses à l'étranger donc peu c'est pas
nouveau c'est c'est eh c'est quelque
chose qui est fait dans tous les
secteurs et pas simplement dans le
secteur de l'armement est bien
reconnaissable industrie de la défense
en france on l'a dit représente 200
mille emplois c'est 13% à des emplois
industriels français cela concerne à
4000 entreprises pour un chiffre
d'affaires de 15 milliards d'euros ça
veut dire que la perte de ce contrat est
ce que c'est une catastrophe pour un
pays comme la france et quel est
l'impact sur le secteur économique
d'abord je voudrais
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
les chiffres si vous voulez sont très
trompeur
quand vous signez un très gros contrat
je vous expliquais quand vous signez un
très gros contrat évidemment votre
chiffres d'exportation d'un seul coup
explose mais en même temps ça veut dire
que ces dix à quinze ans de travail
c'est à dire comment est ce que vous
imputer la charge de travail que ça va
représenter les transferts de
technologie l'entretien etc donc si vous
voulez il ya un espèce de jeu de dupes
qui consiste toujours à dire ben là
cette année ça a été une excellente
année même si ça va et puis ensuite une
mauvaise année même s'il ya pas eu de
gros contrats par contre il ya un socle
vous l'étiez réguliers qui est un choc
si vous voulez de suivi des contrats
anciens déjà signé deuxième remarque sur
les deux cent mille personnes qui
travaillent dans l'industrie de défense
bon je comprends que madame par lee
cherche à grossir les chiffres mais
enfin il ya en gros 100 à 120 mille
personnes qui travaillent directement
ceux des entreprises d'armement le reste
étant des entreprises sous-traitantes
qui évidemment ne font pas que
d'armement donc si vous voulez il ya des
côtés qui nécessitent par exemple sous
titre d'exemple qui est très étonnant en
matière d'exportations d'armements on ne
prend jamais les importations induites
comme si la france fabrique et où depuis
le premier bouton de culotte jusqu'à la
larme de suprématie aérienne alors qu'en
fait on sait très bien qu'il ya des
tôles qui sont importés pour fabriquer
des bateaux on a des éléments qui sont
importés d'ailleurs et ses drames et
parce que ce n'est pas un système
statistique facile après mon bep donc
conclure si vous voulez que là d'un
contrat va être dramatique pour
l'industrie non c'est pas je ne le pense
pas c'est une habitude une entreprise
qui est habitué si vous voulez à subir
des à-coups et deuxième remarque je vous
ferai a même remarqué qu'il ya trois
avions de combat aujourd'hui évidemment
le f 35 qui engrange des contrats il ya
le rafale il ya le typhoon le typhoon
n'est pas en meilleure santé il s'est
surtout vendus en europe donc penser que
la situation est une situation très
concurrentiel et que la france ait pas
effectivement se bat tous les jours le
fait qu'elle maintienne son rang me
paraît plutôt un phénomène relativement
rassurants c'est un c'est une entreprise
de haute technologie servi par des
ingénieurs de l'armement qui sont tous
de très haute
qualité si vous voulez donc je ne
m'inquiète je ne m'inquiète pas vraiment
mais si on va marquer une courte pause
et on revient dans un instant
bienvenue dans ses cages si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine
l'industrie de l'armement en france et
pour en parler nous sommes en liaison
avec pierre connaissent a essayé c'était
ancien haut fonctionnaire pierre
connaissent à la france est aujourd'hui
au troisième rang des pays exportateurs
d'armes derrière les états unis et la
russie comment le pays at il réussi à se
hisser à ce niveau
ben je crois que c'est un héritage de la
tradition du général de gaulle c'est à
dire que le général de gaulle est arrivé
en
58 avec l'idée qu'effectivement la
france devait retrouver un certain
nombre de commandes ird indépendant de
domaine indépendant stratégique et il a
toujours privilégié l'industrie de
défense considérant que c'était
évidemment indispensable à la défense
française mais aussi que c'était un
élément d'exportation important cela dit
la chose a été bien entretenue par tous
ses successeurs est effectivement comme
le disait olivier le président joue
souvent le rôle de vrp dans ce genre
d'affaires cela dit s'il ya une chose
qui est très caractéristique est très
importante aussi c'est que les acheteurs
n'achète que du matériel qu'on appelle
world prouver c'est à dire du matériel
qui a déjà été utilisée en situation de
guerre et donc ça dans ce cas là les
militaires et les ingédients d'armement
joue un rôle essentiel parce
qu'effectivement il explique que lors
que dans un équipement marche donc c'est
une c'est une espèce de commander ans de
tradition colbertiste française si vous
voulez dans lequel vous avez le
politique industrielle le techniques qui
fonctionnent ensemble et c'est
évidemment d'autant plus fort dans le
domaine de armement que ça ne l'est si
vous voulez sur les tgv ou ou sur des
centrales électriques ou et les
moniteurs donc c'est une caractéristique
est effectivement je trouve que dans
l'ensemble la france sera de temps en
temps au troisième temps en temps au
quatrième rang derrière la grande
bretagne mais grosso modo ce soutien il
faut prendre des moyennes lycée si vous
voulez pour avoir une une réelle
indication économique
olivier quand on perd ce genre de
contrat et je crois que c'est pire qu'en
et ça que vous disiez ça à propos de ce
secteur c'est un secteur où tous les
coups sont permis est ce qu'aujourd'hui
on a les moyens en france de riposter
face aux états unis non
non parce que on le voit d'ailleurs où
on se couche quand même systématiquement
est on est on est aux ordres des
américains souvenez vous quand même des
mistral et
c'était c'était un veto américain et on
a on n'a pas livré les deux bateaux
qu'on devait livrer aux russes donc je
pense que
vous avez vous avez le la petite la
petite colère a été de ne pas aller à un
petit raout et de rappeler les les
ambassadeurs américains et australiens
mais bon ça ira pas beaucoup plus loin
que ça à mon avis mais je peux me
tromper et pierre
là je crois que holly pardon olivier a
raison de rappeler la sphère des mistral
parce que cette vente de
porte-hélicoptères système de
commandement s'il voulait et eva avait
été vendu à la russie hees a participé
d'une démarche diplomatique importante
qui était la tradition gaullienne
d'avoir avec des pays qui ne sont pas
des ennemis j'ai encore une fois
j'insiste sur le terme d' ennemi même si
on a des relations compliquées avec eux
des relations de forme de confiance et
c'est un peu face à la même situation qu
on se retrouve aujourd'hui le l'achat de
sous-marins nucléaires par les
australiens déstabilise fondamentalement
toute la zone asie pacifique c'est à
dire que les américains décident de
faire de la prolifération nucléaire
chose qu'ils interdisaient jusque là la
france avait proposé des sous marins
nucléaires à l'australie au début de la
négociation mais les autres années et
est en pleine campagne si vous voulez de
de déni du nucléaire et donc ils avaient
eux-mêmes choisi des sous marins
conventionnels
découvrir aujourd'hui qu'ils préfèrent
des sous marins nucléaires à mon avis a
remporté deux décisions qui sont très
significatives à la différence du
contrat français y aura aucun transfert
de technologie en australie des
américains de transfert paul en
technologies a fortiori quand elle est
du caire les deuxième remarque
effectivement si vous voulez la
situation géopolitique dans la région va
être extrêmement compliqué donc c'est
peut-être là sur le plan diplomatique
plus qu'industriel que la france a un
rôle à jouer et de démonter l'espèce de
discours anti chinois qui aujourd hui
fleuri partout bon est ce que la chine a
agressé qui que ce soit depuis 49 pas
grand monde
mais si on va regarder à ces chiffres à
présent du ministère de la défense 4 3
milliards d'euros c'est le montant qu'a
représenté les livraisons d'armes en
france en 2020 c'est moins 56 % par
rapport à l'année 2010 neuf du côté des
prises de commandes on est à 4 9
milliards d'euros ses 41 % de moins
qu'en 2010 phil ne s'agit pas d'une
tendance de fond à la baisse à rassurer
le ministère des armées alors certes il
ya une crise sanitaire un qui est passée
par là mais est ce que cela signifie que
l'on pourrait perdre notre troisième
place dans les années à venir pendant
les mois à venir
certains dessins oui parce que encore
une fois encore une fois les classements
sont des classements qui sont liées à la
signature de gros contrats donc une
année vous êtes troisième une année vous
êtes 4e et 5e mais fondamentalement
encore une fois c'est la tendance de
moyen long terme si vous voulez qu'il
faut prendre pour la france on défend
effectivement non seulement des produits
qui sont très compétitifs mais en plus
si vous voulez peut-être sont-ils moins
bien appuyé par une ligne diplomatique
qui sert très recentrée sur les
etats-unis après jacques chirac et pépin
aujourd'hui les anglais les américains
considèrent que la france est un vassal
qui n'a qu'à obéir c'est tout donc voilà
je suis regardé la situation à l'égard
de la grèce ils agressent achète
français c'est parce qu'ils savent très
bien que les américains préfèrent
lecture donc on est dans des binômes
comme cela il faut savoir en profiter
diplomatiquement
voyez vous êtes d'accord avec ça ce qui
vient de dire pierre connais ça je vais
compléter aussi parce que les grecs en
fait on leur a pas beaucoup donné le
choix
les grecs aujourd'hui sont totalement
ruiné je pense qu'ils ont autre chose à
faire que d'acheter des rafale mais on
leur a imposé puisque c'est nous qui
avons les cordons de la bourse enfin
nous et les allemands
particulièrement donc quoique ils n'ont
pas eu leur mot à dire lâche on leur a
imposé et qu' il n'était pas question de
d'aller regarder et de faire les yeux
doux aux américains
vu ce qu'on met quand même comme argent
pour parce que les banques centrales m
comme argent la bce pour racheter de la
dette grecque et maintenir ce pays alors
il est complètement en ruines je pense
peut on leur a pas laissé le choix et
puis reconnaît ça est ce que par exemple
un projet de défense européenne pourrait
permettre de mieux lutter contre la
concurrence américaine
écoutez on sent bien que le concept de
défense européen est un concept
extrêmement évanescent qui est très
difficile à mettre en place pourquoi
parce que vous avez un peu toute la boue
l'éventail des postures diplomatiques à
l'égard des états unis tous les pays
d'europe de l'est ancien ancien
satellite si vous voulez quand ils sont
entrés dans l'otan et considère que
c'est le parapluie américain qui les
protège contre la russie vous savez que
la moitié des européens ont suivi les
irak les américains en irak par exemple
al'inverse vous avez des pays comme la
france est comme la loisne qui considère
qu au contraire que effectivement
l'europe devrait être plus actives sur
le sujet
troisième des difficultés si vous voulez
les deux seules armes et qui avait une
capacité de projection et d'intervention
étaient l'armée française et l'armée
britannique bon on l'armée britannique
maintenant on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement elle peut plus entrer
dans le défense européenne donc je crois
que malheureusement c'est un sujet qui
ressemble un peu au monstre du loch ness
qu'on le voit apparaître de temps en
temps mais on n'a jamais rien en faire
une photo fixes et au sens au sens
industriel par exemple une industrie
européenne de la défense il ya déjà
quelques belles réussites de coopération
européen eurocopter est le leader
mondial de la fabrication d'hélicoptères
civils et militaires
airbus est une formidable réussite
encore une fois airbus fait à une
diversification militaires etc donc
c'est vrai que quand on fait en européen
on le fait bien maintenant il y avait un
ancien délégué général pour l'armement
qui sur les matériels militaires en
coopération disait une phrase qui est
restée célèbre dj un chameau c'est un
cheval fabriqué en coopération parce que
chacun demande des spécifications
particulières
pour le matériel qui va fabriquer en
coopération et c'est vrai que tous les
programmes fait en coopération a
beaucoup d'états ont souvent eu
d'énormes difficultés à la réalisation
puis ensuite à l'exportation c'est ce
qu'on a le tornado et ce qu'on connaît
un peu que le typhoon qui ne s'est
exportée en europe pratiquement donc de
la défense européenne effectivement il
faut pas l'articuler complètement avec
l'industriel on s'aperçoit que quand on
laisse les industriels faire ils y
arrivent beaucoup mieux que quand les
états s'en mêle
merci à beaucoup pierre connaisseurs
d'avoir été parmi nous dans cette
émission je rappelle que vous êtes
essayiste ancien haut fonctionnaire et
que votre dernier livre le lobby
saoudien en france est disponible aux
éditions denoël olivier nous on reste
ensemble pour les questions et
commentaires cachent
deux questions cette semaine olivier on
commence avec celle de stef f bonjour
pouvez-vous nous expliquer le problème
de et vers grande
ireland est un promoteur immobilier
chinois qui est le le plus gros
promoteurs immobiliers chinois il a une
dette est juste abyssal qui ne peut pas
rembourser on vous disait souvent ici
que il y avait eu des investissements il
y avait eu des des ghost town donc des
villes complètement vide donc quand vous
avez un promoteur qui
construit une ville entière et puis que
il ya personne dedans pour les pour les
racheter les appartements et bien
évidemment ça finit par faire un trou et
c'est ce qui se passe alors la chine en
profite pour reprendre la main elle a
déjà repris la main sur pas mal de
secteurs le secteur de la formation
en ligne le secteur de 2 des ventes
alibaba monsieur jacques mac qui a passé
quelques
jour où on ne sait pas où il est passé
où on lui a indiqué qu' il fallait
rentrer dans le rang et donc ils vont
reprendre la main là dessus alors après
il y a des grandes banques
internationales comme hsbc et autres qui
sont très impliqués dans la dette de
d'evergrande donc on va voir ce que
comment ça va se passer et qui va rester
sur le carreau et qui sera sauvé
question à présent de pellets obligé si
les états décident d'interdire les
crypto pour faire leur propre crypto
monnaies comme la chine qu'est ce qu'il
se passerait ouais c'est pas qu'est-ce
qui se passerait c est ce qu est ce qui
se passe parce que en effet les états
n'ont pas du tout intérêt à ce que le
lit mission de mener leur échappe et
donc que ils sont en train de tous
essayé de reprendre la main donc vous
avez eu madame lagarde qui veut faire
son neuro numérique et
les chinois qui je vous dis depuis
longtemps et c'est de base et une crypto
peut-être une crypte homo n'est pas sûr
mais sur sur des actifs tangibles
physique et puis vous avez d'autres pays
qui probablement
sont en train d'essayer de faire la même
chose donc ça va se passer et et c'est
ce qu'on disait la dernière phrase c'est
à dire peu à ce moment là ils feront
évidemment tout pour interdire quelque
chose qui pourrait les concurrencer
merci beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant pour découvrir
toutes nos précédentes émissions rendez
vous sur notre site internet à l'adresse
rt france point tv et n'oubliez pas de
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux à cette
émission olivier on se quitte avec le
mot de la fin
boucher ou les